I haven't seen Jim in a while man since
that vas roast I think it was yeah his
last time yeah that was great right that
was fun yeah everybody was talking about
Florentine after the vas roast because I
mean people were so brutal to him the
entire time that people like thought you
weren't gonna be able to come back after
that you destroyed every don't give a
[ __ ] what anybody says go say money or
not the other I seriously I I want I
want to get attacked right I feel like I
feel like bad if I don't and a roast you
say you expect to get brutalize it or
what it is plus if you get attacked like
really badly that gives you free range
to do whatever you want and say whatever
you want to all of them like nobody's
gonna be sitting there and being like Oh
Jim that was a little harsh yeah they
went a little over the line yeah yeah
it's good no I didn't care at all I
never care on a roast I'm just like I
just can't wait to get up there I don't
care what anyone says whatever whatever
the only thing you care about in a roast
is your shake it and stepped on absolute
that's the only thing you care about
it's all [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I wanted to attack
his grandmother's aids Oh No
so you don't even listen to the jokes
about yourself you just listen to the
jokes about other people so you know of
somebody stepping on your jokes or not
pretty much yeah yeah that's all that
really matters yeah just you just cross
it I'm Ally guide and I'm running late
so but not too many jokes got stepped on
which was good so I've helped fill tab
again up there but I don't care what
anyone says I mean that's part of being
on a roast of you if you can't take it
then don't do the roast at all if
there's one thing that you're gonna if
they go after it's gonna make me upset
then don't even sign off at a roast
isn't the worst when somebody's like hey
yeah I'm all for the roast and
everything because you just avoid I've
never had anybody actually say that I've
heard stories of people doing it though
but they say a lot of a lot of the
celebrities that do like yeah Central
roasts have like things that you know I
don't I think the man to some roast
maybe I thought I think I heard that
they said don't touch on the Hep C and
then it was something with Tommy Lee
about to pull some kid drowning it oh
yeah I said don't bring that up okay
maybe that was um
what's-his-face Williams shad William
Shatner yeah oh yeah his wife in the
pool yeah there's certain things he
probably just didn't want what did his
wife Dyer no-win chatter yeah drowning a
[ __ ] these are not comedians off your
celebrity and you decided to do a roast
for a charity
you like I'll do it but can they
probably approach you it's not like with
Voss wear him in his white [ __ ] did the
way was shattered they probably
approached to go do you want to do this
roast and he's like yeah but just
something for my wife dying in a pool
I'm like all right yeah I feel like if
it was a kid dying in a pool I'd go like
yeah okay that's a little over the line
but your wife dying in a pool I think
it's not over the line I feel like can
you i wonder why tall yeah yeah an adult
dying in the pool is fair game a kid
it's like I wouldn't probably go there
anyway so you shouldn't you should have
been negotiating with Shatner yeah she
was a kid she's not your kids she's your
wife like he could have divorced her
anyways he died in a pool like that's
something that people are gonna want to
talk about if celebrities don't have
that you know again they're not comics
they're not used to getting [ __ ]
pounded that much so for them they have
certain things they probably don't want
that's true one good thing about doing
is like besides I know Louis Gomez I'm
not friends with them yeah not enemies
how can you be I just don't know him
that well but other than that all those
guys are my friends so I everything I
said out of my mouth I didn't mean any
of it yeah you don't write him just like
I let me figure an angle on Colin Quinn
let me finger an angle of Jim and rich
and just write about and stuff like that
but I didn't mean any of it so wasn't
mean spirited to me at all even though I
might have came off that's like but
nobody took it that way I don't think so
everybody had a good time I I don't know
anyone that's ever gotten mad at a roast
I don't think at one time I think I got
some I think Tony would you get a little
annoyed at me many many know 15 years
ago what I remember is just mildly I
remember one time that does comic strip
the comedy club in the in New York used
to have a Christmas party every year and
they would show like videos comics to
make videos we watch it and Jim for some
reason went up and just started roasting
people did I yeah yeah yeah yeah you
said something about Mitch Mattel
something about like the kid from Jerry
Maguire wants his personality back like
this is I don't remember that yeah yeah
just were not yeah I guess comments go
up there and talking you went up there
and you roasted like three or four
people oh okay I loved it I was [ __ ] in
the back Howard those parties really
weird to you go Andy it was an afternoon
party for the comic strip there holiday
party Louie would always make these
weird little movies that he would show
these bizarre little like homemade films
was really a weird vibe would they do
them in the afternoon
don't want to close the club at night um
possibly uh they want to keep the club
open for the yeah whatever but chiselers
yeah like a Sunday afternoon I'm boss
brought this girl with them from Jersey
as a date to the party and I started
rapping with her and he's like he's like
he goes look I go no he goes comes over
he goes what's going on here guys just
talking about jurors he goes talk he
goes dude you could [ __ ] her but just
give her a ride back to Jersey cuz I
don't feel like I don't feel like taking
her back just he goes but you can [ __ ]
are absolutely but just give her a ride
all right cool I don't want to drive
rolling back to Princeton that's too far
that's ridiculous that really was a very
generous guy when it came to that stuff
people I don't care just take its no
feelings there's no attachment to it he
doesn't take it as an ego shot with
himself classes autism got me laid a few
times just gets bored of somebody it's
like look you can have her but I love to
it's like it's like it like a king right
like it's just like the women are just
they're either gonna [ __ ] the king or
whoever the king tells them to right
exactly look just go [ __ ] this guy I
gotta go the best boss story ever is um
that Rascals comedy club down in down
gem ocean ocean yeah an ocean Township
on a Tuesday night Foss picks his girl
up and they're gonna get a hotel there's
a hotel like on 35 north it's a Tuesday
so there's nobody staying at a hotel
right in a millage erzsi so they pullin
in a parking lot and a girl wants of
blowing him in the car before to even
get into the hotel so he comes and then
he's like right now I want to get out he
goes I don't want to get a hotel so he
go he goes live let me go to the front
desk and look at a room he comes out
like five might say goes they're all
sold it was nobody here cuz known as the
buck bunch of busses in the back this
big parties there's no rooms
[Laughter]
she blue thinking like I'm gonna make
him come now it's just almost like an
appetizer ugh this is gonna be a crazy
night we're gonna get a hotel room it's
gonna be luxurious and he's like I
already came like right now I'm done
thing you want to do is get a hotel if
someone after you blow a load I know so
yeah just matter what is he gonna do so
it's yeah she's probably thinking right
now we're gonna have amazing sex and
right we get this one at it away I bet
we're gonna get a hotel room now he'll
go down on me right and then after that
we'll probably and he's like he should
at least return the favor right and
we're gonna meet we can do that in a car
like you can but it's a little difficult
and he's like no it's uh so what about
that story you invoice with these girls
in Vegas you would you were in a hotel
room I mean you guys were hitting on him
all night till like 6:00 7:00 in the
morning finally boss goes to the girl
look are you gonna sleep with me or not
just be honest with me
I could take it and she goes no but he
goes you sure he goes no and he just
started farting that's very familiar
I don't remember just no patience and
he's not even like like he'll accept
that answer at that point yeah he's like
I'm good he goes on you're not gonna
hurt my feelings I just want to know if
I can let these out or not yeah if it's
not gonna happen tell me now and it's
not it doesn't take that it's not
because he wants the challenge it's
because he wants to fart yeah he's just
done he's done trying like he I thought
one time we [ __ ] around that one
female comedian years ago where she was
like laying between us we're both on
each side of her jerking off and at one
point she got up and then it was just
meeting him on the bed and then she had
to come back it was just too creepy
because it was what the three of you
naked now he's had her dicks out and she
was in the middle of playing with her
tits
so [ __ ] boss won't like him can we
just lay next to you and jerk off yeah
she don't think she didn't want to [ __ ]
either one of us uh-huh but I remember
uh boss looked over me and he goes right
like I'm gonna flip a coin whoever loses
mr. [ __ ] he comes first and then he
goes to the bathroom and she had a cat
and there was cat [ __ ] in the bathroom
and I'm jerking off with this girl he's
here
he's a real piece of garbage what a
scumbag yeah yeah complete scumbag yeah
but after all that he's the one who's
like married with a family right yeah is
it weird like like I haven't [ __ ]
around like and done that with one of my
buddies in a long time but that's how I
know all my friends are getting
responsible and getting married and
having kids and stuff like that I've
never had those experiences and I mean
if you're still doing that at 49 isn't
that a little like I mean even the 90s
especially when most of the [ __ ] went
down they were more into like two guys
on them instead of like now it's like
two chicks and a guy the three of them
has changed yet it was always so it was
always dude so why is that girls always
wanted two guys in the room rarely did
you get two women at the same time I
don't think I ever pulled it off on the
road two guys women two women know how
Lord I had to what me and Jim picked up
girls when Simon's [ __ ] North
Carolina and I gave such a lousy
performance I had to watch him [ __ ] his
girl really well in the next bed he did
better than you oh my god he was [ __ ]
hair in our part were you finished
before he was gonna [ __ ] her my dick
would need her so just eating her [ __ ]
I was wearing all black it was creepy
this is an amazing story so we had a
deal that we're playing in like Raleigh
North Carolina it's like nine hours away
so we switch a Saturday night we're
going over to gig I said all right look
if we meet girls were staying tonight if
we don't mean any we're gonna drive home
and Jim's up all night so he'd rather
drive through tonight and he's like I
fair enough so at the end of the show
this girl comes over and she starts
rapping with me and Jim's ready to go
because there's no other girls around
and I can look you got I gotta be I go
my friend wants to leave we gotta go
back to Jersey tonight you know what are
we gonna do she goes no we're gonna [ __ ]
I'm like to just can you guarantee me
that because I don't want to stay
tonight cuz he really wants to go she
goes no believe me we're gonna have a
good time ago Jim kind of mean hey ya
and Jim was [ __ ] pissed but he's like
I got to do it much my friend we have to
do it yeah he's got a question a girl is
telling you like no no no no do not go
home yes she said we're [ __ ] home so
we go to this like sports bar and we're
sitting there and she goes I have a
friend from for your friend she shows up
she's like 300 pounds yes she was
and when you know that you're talking to
was she good-looking yeah she was like
an eight and a half years very very
attractive took the one I took her in
the bathroom and [ __ ] her in the
bathroom is Jim stalking that girl at
the table her friend keeping the fatty
occupied yeah he took a bullet for me
because he didn't say where's my friend
they've been gone a long time
he was a professional he was asking her
how she likes her steaks done you know
so Jim's miserable but he's like iron I
got a hang what am I gonna do and then
the fat girl leaves and she goes I have
an assault son this other girl shows up
like a 9 no the fat girl stayed and the
other the other girl showed up and the
four of the five of us were talking were
you attracted to the big girl I was not
even as a person I hated her but do you
remember that I finally started doing
well with this pretty girl talking about
being a vegan or animal right and then
you ran blocker on the fat one who kept
saying she wanted to go yes so you and
the other girl we're keeping the fat one
occupied for me now and I'm talking to
this attractive one and then we wanted
to get out of there the four of us and
the fat one wanted to go home oh no the
fat wanted to leave and her friend in
fairness what all right you you are I'll
see you later
and the minute girls let her leave yeah
you think friend groups would figure out
like who's who in the group like if the
girl who is obviously not there for the
same reasons as the other is like trying
to convince the group to leave it's like
you know it's not your spot well she she
had an attitude that's why Jim didn't
like her to begin with like she you know
the fat one but Jim was basically a debt
death's door with the fat one he was so
miserable talking to and this nine
showed up and this he [ __ ] perked up
me they pulled it out of his nowhere I
don't know I didn't know her I didn't
know where he was and he was just on a
roll with this one and they were just
talking back and forth and then Isis
started talking at a fat one I mean a
friend is just keeping her busy Ram was
a gym converted and then a half hour
later us four went back to the hotel
room and they let the girl leave the fat
girl leave in fact usually they'll stick
with their girlfriend but they're like
all right and and she loved it but then
I couldn't do anything
how so no you were eating a box for a
long time I finally took up to my room
but why couldn't you get hard if like
you would think that the happiness of
being like oh my god I was always stuck
with this fat chick and he pulled out a
nine well this is my friend was in the
room who's we
and I was making noises yeah yeah it was
just killing me
he had an eight and a half and you had a
nine you said yeah so like you think
like I know what he's got I've got the
hot a chick like this is exciting we
were it was double beds we're you know
obviously really close to each other we
heard one he was on the other I would
look over and Jenny's going down on her
for like an hour right or push for a
while yeah I did did you have trouble
getting hard he did not please it bother
you that my family's watching now yeah
it didn't the whole like all my buddies
in the room it didn't bother you yeah I
thought it was funny right yeah bug me I
couldn't do it I've done a few of those
but it's always weird here as a friend I
did take her up to my room after that
and I ate a [ __ ] for a while but she
was one of those girls who couldn't come
know like she'd get really close and
then she'd stop you so she couldn't come
and you couldn't get hard he meant for
each other but yeah no wonder your
conversation was so good nothing else
was well she she would get up close to
chew uh-uh and then she would physically
push you off it was one of those like
you there's something blocking isn't
that amazing like you get out of nowhere
you have unbelievable game with this
girl that's way too hot for you you
never think it's gonna happen you get
her upstairs and you have the worst sex
of your life the oral sex with girl I
enjoyed it a [ __ ] but she just couldn't
come but it's just like I think I I'm
guessing she blew me I don't remember I
mean I'll tell you but well you were
busy doing your own thing he was banging
that one and you kept in touch with that
one but the other one would never get
back to me none too pleased I kept in
touch with her for a while but it was I
remember what we were offered his show
on vh1 me and Jim to be like roommates
and some TV show whatever it is pilot
and we could wait I guess we had a call
back like two days later and we're
sitting in there with the directors now
in the room like all the big people are
in the room and I'm right before we sit
down the guy goes so you guys are
friends in real life and then Jim
decides to tell the whole story what to
the director and there's a woman there
and stuff how yeah Jim I was eating a
[ __ ] and Jim was making these noises
yeah and they were they were wrote that
the directors like holy [ __ ] and they
all started laughing they're like this
is so shocking that this is actually
funny and we got the gig
and if Michael Rosen yeah Michael Rosen
and then did whoever to direct the time
there's a bunch of people and that's
another thing about 90s he told nineties
that [ __ ] was like that acceptable yeah
that would have gotten you a gig now if
you did it they'd be like we did two
versions of that pilot I think in that
pilot all the time me and Jim did this
that one time we did one here I think
one they flew us to LA for MLA and the
first one was really funny they let us
ride around just after they put this
[ __ ] lame douchey la writer on the
the one we didn't know it's a premise it
was like a beavis and butthead thing
where you're sitting there as roommates
watching videos and commenting and there
was three couples it was me and Jim
we're like buddies we're just roommates
what was your name Jerry and I remember
our names were something in Jerry why
did if you're just watching videos
making I lived in the same apartment
complex who were in different apartments
like five four different couple
preparing people if they're a narrative
to it like they would just go from
apartment oh yes why can't you use your
real names then I don't remember that's
how they wrote it yeah something Jerry
Jerry and something they gave us these
Han and the girl and there was a girl
who actually wanted marrying Barry Katz
Suzanne that she was one of those she's
an actress at the time her and this
other guy played a couple and that is
who gay guys wife was in a bath Ostrosky
was in it well she was in this she was
in the original one in New York yeah was
she
yeah who did she was she married to like
the good I didn't member she was in that
yes she was in it yeah was she married
she's like the good looking guy there's
like a regular couple I think so yeah I
was Beth Ostrosky
yeah we run a set with her one day and
we're like hi and she was just wanted
just look right through us
strung out yeah I mean it wasn't
instantaneous yeah I mean yeah I think I
remember that yeah yeah I said the hot
girl said who wanted nothing to do this
but vh1 actually hired us for writers so
we had a writing gig we're in like 1515
Broadway in a building sitting in a room
writing the scripts from being Jim they
hired us and we're in this little room
and we just farting the all day dropping
guessers and we count them we have a
little counter 1 2 3 / 5 10 look I think
Jim had like 43 one great and what we do
we do we call over like an intern go
look there's something wrong with the
computer can you come in here and check
it out and there was nothing wrong
I wouldn't say anything cuz using
internal what about there it's can you
track this IQ from in the room as long
as price to pro do sir the guy running
the whole thing we'd make him come in
the room hey could you check this script
out just go so I'll be right down and
just walked into a wall of farts did he
say anything he'd give us the finger
[ __ ] I remember we went out to LA to
shoot we did go out to LA to shoot the
second part of the pilot the first one I
thought was good matarese was in one of
them they shot at first what memories
yeah with me and Jim they didn't use us
for one version and they're like okay we
want to use you guys to not see La
that's reassuring and I remember I well
they realize the error of their ways and
then they shot the second version with
us and I remember I blew my whole per
diem on out escort the first night we
got there cuz she said she look like Pam
Anderson yeah there's 300 bucks was my
per diem for the week by food money for
the week right and I [ __ ] blew it on
a prostitute days whatever it was all up
front yeah cash and envelope and he got
yeah and I remember looking out the
window because I wanted to see what she
looked like because they're saying like
this apartments yeah that's what I think
I Drive by that pretty often wherever
that was I see that unlike I think that
pilot is responsible he's out on the
balcony look and I wanted to see this
Pam Anderson look and I just sort of
back America it doesn't look like not
all at all she's not Pam Anderson we
wasted all your per diem money I don't
wire yeah I don't even know if I had a
credit card back then I might have I was
like 1995-97
ladies yeah but no no I knew dice it was
like 97 97 98 yeah oh my god that is so
like yeah that's really a response and
then we had dice come down to do a part
in a pilot Oh dice is like I want to be
on your show so we got dice in the pilot
and they didn't use the scene with him
these [ __ ] Wyatt idiots because it
was a weird thing or at the Emma or me I
I find pictures of us
you were so skinny back then yeah Jim
looked sick like you would really really
slim yeah I was like a 160 yeah well we
were [ __ ] sit there and icicles I
want you to spit your gum in my face so
that was what dice had we do we were
doing some scene he had me grab him and
go shut up and spit my gum in his face
it was really funny and like we don't
think your character would do that it's
funny douchey writer oh yeah
come and introduce clays face that's
funny I remember Jim wanted to uh Jim
wanted to say [ __ ] and a joke oh god
yeah instead and they go can you can you
say a special needs just giving you one
say [ __ ] 97-98 not for vh1 no I
remember the context of the joke but I
remembered they go just do one version
of saying special needs and Jim's like
now no cuz you're gonna use that version
he goes no we just want to have it goes
now no I'm not doing it freaking
wouldn't do it he's like yeah I think
that was the later version too but with
the new writer I think I remember his
name yeah yeah terrible where is he
justice Crockett la cornere Tommy got
the LA the script was so bad we're like
this is the worst garbage ever is that
when you realize this isn't happening
yeah I've been working on this and doing
different versions and then you get to
LA and you're like oh it's dead like I
remember I was saying let's let's go on
a comedy sent a copy Sandler stage and
read this script and see if there's any
laughs in it no because we did a table
read and there was no laughs at all well
the first one the still we had a
storyline ongoing and it was about the
pretty girl in the second with Beth I
didn't it was a pretty girl moved into
the building and we found her underwear
in the in the dryer
yeah and that was the storyline that our
that was kind of tied in the so really
was like a live-action beavis and
butt-head in a way yeah let me get a
copy of that because any copies that
exist I have some some tape and I'd the
first one that we didn't think so yeah
we wrote a script there was a gay couple
mm-hmm these two guys so we wrote a
script and ours and Jim script is the
beginning like the cold-open is the gay
couple and they had a pet gerbil and the
gerbil is missing that was our cold-open
the gay guys go Jeffrey what did you do
with the gerbil yeah that was a and then
it goes to the credits the opening
credits great that was not called all
but two gay guys in his wondering
there's a church service missing and we
saw the other copy that they do at
matarese wasn't that god-awful yeah
god I would kill to see those again yeah
I would love to hear
we were you were in the movie was were
you at you were in there's a star of it
yeah we were talking about was it was
this plant play the song here Jim
recognized it don't say the name Jim
okay so Jim picture this do you
recognize this song you're going to your
yeah just for yeah see if you recognize
them Travis of [ __ ] don't play from the
beginning it's just a little bit yeah
well of course
yeah just see if you recognize it oh
[Music]
yeah there it is down join the party
what do you what else do you do at the
best apart join the party and remember
the other grab a hottie do you think
those lyrics are cool no but just my
friend Kevin's band he knows that Kevin
this is his band that they did game this
song for it I noticed one right
I know it's Kevin yeah yeah well he's
he's singing backups in this song yeah
the fourth floors name we were analyzing
this scene one morning because nobody
took time to mention the fact that it's
like a it's a pool party but it's
obviously an autumn day in New Jersey
you know there are leaves on the ground
and also everybody's grouped into one
the same part of the pool they were
doing it in one quick shot yeah I'm
really bad guys called out yet only I
think way no Drano jumped in the pool or
something like James jumped in the pool
it was reason who was dirty in this guy
this guy was great yeah his autumn this
guy from New Jersey will attack what
made this guy low he said I wrote a
script I want to make this movie I want
to shoot around 35 millimeter film did
you shoot a 35 million yeah back in like
why don't whatever this was 97
I think there's before then there's X 5
96 he spent like a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars on his ear to sell his
house he lost everything
150 grand to cost them to shoot out 35
millimeter film he didn't pay any of us
we didn't get paid no 100 any other
sellers house because he thought he was
gonna sell us movie
did he sell it no oh it wasn't a
particularly great film did he get the a
trickle release at all I know no no I
know you know what your butt was later
than that because you and I were you and
I were living together I think I took I
took your ex's sister Maddie I took her
she came with me to the premiere yeah
there was a premiere party in New York
and smile never was in the whole Balkan
Film Festival like eight years ago or
seven years I didn't win an award a
10-year anniversary of it no we just 18
years ago we did this yeah I think so
this is what's it called white chicks
incorporated yeah yeah yeah yeah we
desperately we've ripped you don't have
a copy of it do you a boss is in the
movie too yeah do you have the movie do
you have a copy if I should have a copy
of MA you guys do you want to see it not
only here's what we're gonna do if you
can find it I don't care if it's on VHS
not only will we watch the entire movie
live on the air we will do a live event
we should do a live premiere where the
audience together like we need to
premiere this movie we need to but it's
not good
I bet it's all right I'll bet you're
remembering it differently and maybe
you're right
do you member how hot that stripper
Awards that I had to [ __ ] do this
thing Wow was she beautiful out like a
couple scenes so we can watch him on the
air but then the whole movie gets
premiered in front of an audience of all
radio fans all you're gonna hear is
booing yeah it was things being thrown
yeah you got a pen you gotta find this
movie because Jim doesn't have a copy
Norton so you got it you gotta know you
got him to dig for it I think I think I
might have probably PHS I love that it's
not and if it's on VHS we'll hook up a
VCR to a projector like we'll do it
right from the VHS no need to transfer
just let's let's get it in all its VHS
glory I love that in the film is he I
don't move yeah I know
I forget he does I think in a comedy
clubs he's a comedian working or
something yeah yeah he's making fun I
think me an already Fletcher you get a
fitting tribute to Otto
yeah he's up there just doing Otto okay
so he's actually good yeah okay just do
an exact yeah I've lost played the club
on it go say your mommy we play that
Opie and Anthony we played parts of it
fosters part was not particularly good
no we got it we got to air the whole
movie and I don't know tread do you know
anybody who can do a 4k restoration I'm
we could we could look into it I'll
probably stick with just the VHS sure I
think so
I've seen footage with three KS it's
gonna get bigger laughter I think this
is the way it was meant to be seen
there's definitely theaters in the city
or Brooklyn that that can do this we
could do it at the Gramercy yeah I mean
they do they've agreed a projector
that's true the Gramercy and then we get
here's what we'll do we'll do it at the
Gramercy we'll play the movie and then
we'll get everybody that we can find who
was involved to do a Q&A with the
audience
and every question will be why would you
so we meet you / Emmys around Artie's
around yeah Artie Fletcher our voice man
is in and he's around I'll volunteer to
moderate I don't know if it'll be
necessary I think so no I don't know I
don't know I won't I promise I won't
skew the question yeah I don't think
it's a positive way what's happening oh
I see him once in a while oh you do
probably about seven years ago he came
out to a gig that I was doing at Jersey
Wow
yeah hit the sellers house yeah he had
this uncanny ability to get a lap dance
and come in his pants but he could he
can he can do it like three different
times like tonight yeah then about an
hour
Wow three and then he would just walk
around like that I'm like going he's
gonna go home and changes now whatever
doesn't matter cuz three comes out all
over his pants yeah like in his pants
I'm just grinding on him and it has
genes on but if you're if you respect
that a lot and he would say cuz why do I
need a girlfriend I'm like it's a good
point if you come in your pants right
and then like a half hour later you're
getting another lap dance isn't that um
that's in your pants getting all over
your [ __ ] I didn't ask him Thanks hey
man buddy gross I was at the strip club
where do I go yep that's number two when
they come out of the back room that's
three I mean he did Club by the way I
saw one of the girls in the movie she
was so mad that he took me there she I
don't think she want me to know she was
a dancer right oh she's so [ __ ] hot
just physics though like you get calm
all over yourself right I mean
theoretically yeah yeah that's
disgusting
he lives in Jersey it's a great trade
it's a great skill to have isn't that
yeah three in an hour yeah it's really
good because you talking about
people he's the guy who's figured out
Vegas like he's going to the strip club
in the system he's not wasting a cent
like that the strip club is designed to
just get money out of you to just drain
your pockets of whatever money you have
every dollar he's spending is is
worthwhile and then he's out
I've only pulled off two loads of my
pants and strip clubs in my life only
twice I want other ones I guess no and
what I told Joey Diaz when he was in
there that one story with that that high
roller took me that strip club and then
once in New Orleans never be able to
pull that off though what happened in
New Orleans cuz I was wearing satin
boxers I wasn't doing a gig with P Cory
Ali and Luis Ramos yeah this is a
professional satin boxers of course on
Bourbon Street and I she want me to win
the VIP area which is like 300 bucks and
this is a college gig back in the late
nineties I had no money right you didn't
have a pretty him to waste no nothing
and I remember I was like I'm getting
close and I [ __ ] I blew load my pants
and Lewis Ramey and P Corey are outside
the club so I open my pants I showed
them the mess how great is this [ __ ]
dude appreciate myself I pulled it off
but the other the other guys weren't
proud no that was creeped out by it yeah
I wouldn't want to see her you're
calming your pants no I would be if
you're like hey Sam check this out it I
didn't want to yeah they didn't do I did
too and 44 minutes I timed it what two
of my p.m. in your pants yeah that's one
strip club that closed the club owner no
me and a couple other guys those with so
we just said whatever you guys want
so we picked out like the hottest girls
this Dallas just grind and know it was
in Jersey and just grind in us and I'd 2
and 44 minutes Wow yeah well that was
unbelievable I was working in as Sam
Goody and the second one didn't know and
it came a little out because I had the
head out a little oh if you're pokin out
a little bit was just poking out a
little bit because I go well you got to
get the leverage when you go back to you
can't have it hanging down right move it
up but you were poking it out of your
pants okay came out a peaked out a
little when she was grinding on me and
it went on a dress I just had jeans on
so you unzipped your flight and just
come out no you know I didn't had room
so you know it stuck out I know what
he's saying that the helmet was just
poking out of house ball not out of the
pants altogether
no no just a helm was poked but out of
the boxers so it was like it was no no I
just had it up like this it was just
against your stomach so the waistband
didn't get so you get the grinding so
you get the ass and you dick stay still
and it's like jerking off yeah
yes in the so it's tucked up in the
waistband yeah and maybe your shirt like
a nice dress on and she was just grind
and I mean it was music playing so she
didn't know and I and I came and I'm
like hard I'm good that's it you're sure
I'm like yeah yeah I'm fine she'd had no
idea what happened and she went to put a
dress on cuz I guess I got all of her
dress oh I remember walk out she goes I
just [ __ ] storm that around let's get
the [ __ ] outta ya because that's not
security's not gonna be happy
come on a stripper surprised if she'd
never had that before there's gotta be
very common guys to blow their loads in
the [ __ ] lap dance room yeah probably
Butchie I don't think she knew cuz I
just said yeah I'm good she's like you
sure I'm like a that's fine that's
that's but that's you dude like when
you're like I I came in my pants but it
got all over her that's not coming your
parents that's not technically coming in
your pants but your pants are on thumb
isn't in your pant you came on you came
on her have you doubt it realizing it
have I know yeah I have I I worked with
a guy when I was working at Sam Goody at
the record store who he and really I
guess he didn't get out much because we
weren't at a strip club like we just
went out like and it was like a club or
something it was a dance club and a girl
was grinding on him at the club but just
like dancing at a dance club and he came
in his pants on a dance that's hardcore
yeah he came in his pain but he was
wearing khakis so like you could you
could see cuz it gets darker you know
right so everybody knew I knew I knew a
sober guy would go to sober dances and
he was able to come in his pants
sometimes before grinding whoo you get
pre-cum so he would put a baggie over
his dick oh my god I remember he told me
he would put like a [ __ ] little
plastic baggie over his dick so he
didn't it didn't show through his pants
or it might not have been full calm but
he didn't get but he'd be going to sober
dances dances with my intention of
coming in a briny yeah that's what is it
what a problem I think it's great it's a
good problem it saves you such a [ __ ]
headache
if you blow load in your pants your
night is done exactly you've got a plane
house money the rest of the night right
who cares what Ryan's right you've
already got your winnings and they're
locked in the safe deposit box and you
and your whatever they're locked in the
safe in your hotel room the rest of the
money it's just fun money yeah just like
I you know yeah I'm good you get to lose
it all it doesn't matter you don't need
to go you know you don't need to bring
anybody back home no because what are
you gonna do with them
Troy you come in your pants yeah twice
once when I was a kid just hooking up
with a chick you're just so excited to
be actually be with a girl yeah and
you're grinding it just you know sure
it's all right but then it wasn't at a
bachelor party which was a lot of fun oh
you were happy about it yeah of course
lap dance yeah well she was like I mean
she was pretty much jerking me off
through my pants but yeah you finish and
you're like this is great like the gun
is unloaded just hanging out with the
guys now and talk it's just like have
fun with your friends right it becomes
like a thing where you're like you're
just thinking about I haven't come yet
haven't come I gotta come I gotta come
it's a thing that you have to you have
to settle and once it's settled
you're like okay I just enjoy myself
everything is good after that no problem
I see these game and I don't have to
deal with not one ounce of [ __ ]
there'll be no [ __ ] no doing
anything I don't want to do because I
got [ __ ] in my pan yeah there used to be
this guy booked I forget what it was he
was booked bachelor parties in like
[ __ ] Lalique Jersey somewhere like so
we're like you know rural Pennsylvania
outside of Philly and I would do them a
lot but they were all the girls were
escorts so it was great you do the guys
you do 20 minutes [ __ ] kill be filthy
and then the girls would come in and do
dances and you just take an escort in
the [ __ ] bathroom and get along it
was the best gig I ever did they were
all here they're all like dancers who
would do extra for a few bucks bright
but they weren't that expensive
they weren't the highest they were sighs
melody no they weren't
discounted very cheap I don't remember
well it's been again you know 1995 but
affordable yeah at that time it was very
affordable I was going home to mother
and father's house so I didn't have
rented my name is Spector well that's
amazing it was great
I didn't wait to do this this movie
screening this will be fun if we can get
a copy of it yeah get Lou yeah yeah I
could track him down if I can't find a
VHS
yeah
and I like it even better if it's on VHS
I don't want a DVD or anything but it
might break tell you when you watch it
you gotta have a DVD backup yeah we
could make a backup we can make a few
copies but yeah I think it'll work on
VHS I bet I bet the Gramercy has VCRs
right if not we'll bring one you just
have to plug it in go to rental center
yeah sure you don't want to do like a
pool parties forever
well here's the thing if we do a pool
party screening we'll have to wait till
the fall to the film yeah yeah yeah
we'll have to do it on like a day that's
like you know 48 degrees all the leaves
are changed colors already yeah
the sky is overcast it might rain at any
moment that was such a bed not a good
film was fun for us weekend yeah okay
we're on a movie set you know what I
mean there's chicks around and we're
acting and stuff sure the dude is
investing money in it yeah you know oh
yeah thirty five-millimeter right I was
just you know the real deal do you
remember we did that other film it was
not a good one of your friend who to the
comic book store robbery it was a comic
book store robbery are you and McMahon
started I think I had a small part in it
yeah your friend was difficult yeah yeah
cuz yeah he wanted us to stick more to
the script and we're trying to ad-lib I
don't even like that now cuz I you know
I understand that if someone writes like
hey this is my vision and weird yeah
well yeah we're trying to crack like
hooker jokes and stuff like that right
yeah constantly but yeah but you know
all that shit's good to do yeah just to
get training for when you're on a real
set did you guys think that white chicks
incorporated was gonna be like a big
movie like did you think cuz you're
young and you're optimistic no I didn't
even when you know I didn't I remember
being in the screening and I was like
it's not that it's aged poorly it was
aged appropriately I remember who was in
the city we did a screening in the city
and I remember my family's like you
wanted let's rent your limo to go to
what I don't know no I'm just I'll take
the subway there oh yeah they don't need
a limo they won't make a big deal out of
them like knots you do not - yeah it's
yeah and then you get there and you're
like nobody's ever gonna see this movie
well we had all our friends in the
audience today will laughing attic
they knew us wait a screen it you
remember I forget where it was but did
the guy who made it that he realized
that like he thought it was gonna be
great I remembered like going through
the process with him and stuff he's like
this is gonna be amazing I'm gonna sell
this thing gonna be huge stars when
you're screening it it's like don't you
realize you just sold your house for
something that a bunch of buddies you're
just getting together to laugh at what
we didn't know at the time at the time
you know what he wrote the whole script
we changed some stuff and obviously but
he already really thought it cuz this is
gonna be it you know he was already
making Saigon I already looked at
flights for Sundance oh really
yeah he's like so I'm just getting well
you know I submitted it so we'll see I
mean I didn't end up going to Sundance
it did not know unless it was in a
suitcase anyone went to safety dance man
I was not good you didn't go to Sundance
did not know but I remember Artie
Fletcher's won a comic friend was he won
a banging the director doing them
darkness during a filming of it it was
raining right yeah and then he was
banging another girl on the set it was
what a super bad they're fun yeah I
forgot about her yeah the director she
was nice yeah why didn't he direct it if
he wrote it I think he just wanted to be
in the business yeah he just want to be
like a producer in the business oh I see
yeah I see man I want to know how those
things work out and the movies are great
too every once in a while you'll hear
about one that works out but you're not
one of those cases this wasn't one of
those I think he throws not be like the
next clerks
he wasn't similar to clerks but I
thought he think you put guy from Jersey
yes a low-budget low-budget where
there's a problem with the 90s right the
clerks came out and it was made for
nothing it was black-and-white it was
just you know shot on location in a
store like what are you spend like 27
grand or something made everyone think
they could do a movie everybody put Plus
Kevin Smith's dialogue was so everyman
dialogue and what it was just like jokes
that you would make with your buddies or
whatever that yeah everybody especially
in Jersey thought well yeah I mean this
is what movies look like now I'm gonna
be the next Kevin Smith and nobody was
the next Kevin no none of them none of
them no no I think that's one Blair
which came out yeah 20 grand and I never
got a million or something yeah I can
put together 20 grand yeah and be a big
famous movie maker I could do this and
it never it didn't pan out
you know uh not for any of us it's so
funny yeah fun to do though
oh yeah we had a blast I'm sure there's
a few of those you look back on you like
wow that's not good but it's almost fun
or to do because of how bad it was
yeah in hindsight right in hindsight
because you have done good things since
then yeah I've done a few yeah yeah you
just look back at some of the stuff like
I used to do a Steven Wright impression
on stage and oh my god around first like
that but even when I turn back around I
was still the same guy I didn't do any
facial expression yeah and that's my
hair I did why'd you turn around
it's a good impression though I don't
know I just did because everyone used to
do impressions they used to turn around
first he's turned around in a character
to your question it was pretty good I
can't remember so I can doing an
impression of another comic yeah it was
like because I had these like like goofy
one line or so I figured out this would
be more like Steven Wright well these
are Steven Wright type Joe typewriter my
act yet it in front of my act so let me
do them as Steven Wright did work no I
remember one of the jokes we will we're
making fun of Steven writer just know I
was just a decent you were just kind of
stealing his act he wrote jokes that he
thought wouldn't work for him even if I
do mean to Steven right impression these
will kill yeah you didn't think to
yourself like oh I thought of this joke
but since it doesn't fit in my act I'll
just let it go yeah I just said well if
I do as Steven Wright impression right
you should've just let it go I should
have let it go or sell it to somebody or
something if the jokes are that
brilliant find Steven Wright and be like
hey when you want to buy some jokes oh I
know one of the jokes
yeah can you do it as Steven Wright if
you have to turn around that's a boy
well yeah I don't even know how Steven
Wright tell I haven't seen it in a long
time but one of the jokes was um I broke
my toe the other day so I called a tow
truck that's the one I was thinking of I
had a call a tow truck that is so bad
there's a couple of like I should I do
my time is low the jokes would do badly
wasn't the time no is the writing the
jokes would bomb and at the end he would
wrap up the impression I go and see all
right thank you
[Laughter]
you just kept doing it
well yeah five jokes on it or some other
one of us did it more than one so you
wouldn't worry
did it ever work I maybe got a gut few
chocolate Oh truck yeah I broke my toes
so I called a tow truck a tow truck why
would a truck fix your toe
it wasn't good job just cuz it's called
tow truck yeah it's tio w no I know
oh I'm trying to think any other I can
for the get the other one but yet but I
would pause in there it was a little
pause but no I never but I guess I just
needed the time we were probably doing
30 minutes when we were we didn't really
have traction to 30 extension to 30 so I
figure out that you like two or three
minutes right you had UX 20 you're 25
and you're like but I got to get to 30
yeah so let me do these bad Steven write
jokes because I know they were clean so
I knew like these comedy clubs that when
me and Jim would work I'm they were like
the headliner what [ __ ] if we were
dirty dirty Angie I see somebody's
always crying we were on the show so I
said god I got a clean act just a
feature for this guy to do 30 minutes so
I throw that in there cuz I knew that
was clean
did you ever run jokes by Norton like
hey what do you think of this I broke my
toe I called a tow truck I don't know
why should we were two times from
running by each other because I was
encouraging though Florentine was always
encouraging he was fine yeah he was
always good yeah I mean no Jim we'd
always go up there and kill he had a lot
of hot he was high energy and stuff like
that but he was always killing and we
you know we didn't know what he better
we just would like God this is what we
came up with it yeah if you laughs oh
[ __ ] it you meant what an awful gig
Jenkins's was Jenkinson's in the south
her in the [ __ ] Jersey she was a good
Oh an open-air [ __ ] Jersey barge was
terrible Otto would always destroy there
I never go out on time and there's a guy
in the front row in a wheelchair and
Otto goes what are you waiting for a
better seat oh that's great yeah it was
fun that's great that was the one that
plays Jenkinson's it was a place down to
Jersey Shore this was like the early 90s
when I had long hair and my brother's my
bra was a big ball busters came in Jim
yeah Sam and Jim at that point and we
were on a family vacation and I was over
in the corner and this girl was at the
bar my brother's getting beers and this
girl goes is
bon jovi over there and of course my
brothers go yeah we're with them he said
that's John Bonzo we should yeah oh my
god what is he doing down he's like well
he's recording an album I'm on vacation
with his family like Oh what can I go
say hello to him he's like a hold on my
older brother comes over goes this chick
thinks you're Bon Jovi I go oh so we're
bringing her home so he doesn't say like
the smart thing to do would be like how
I talked to him he doesn't really want
to do the fan thing right now he's with
it because you're not my Jovi no I know
but he said we're bringing the girls
over yeah so the girl comes over and
she's like John and my brother goes look
she thinks she'd find you always they
just play along so it's like John I'm
like yeah thanks your voice
there's nothing Bon Jovi ish about him
at all like why is this I always had
hair like Bon Jovi like whatever I want
Jovi had when he caught it I cut mine I
said I'm gonna follow what he's doing
shots elf face like Bon Jovi yeah with
the hair dye when the blondie I don't
know it was dark
obviously wasn't a fan she just probably
knew who Bon Jovi was or watched a newer
video so she didn't know intimately what
he looked like I don't know like Jon Bon
Jovi's are really he's known for being a
really good singer right yeah yeah so
like his speaking voice probably
wouldn't like really everyone didn't
really know his speaking voice but it's
definitely not that well you didn't know
those Jim with the long hair Jim look
like Rocky Bon Jovi yeah like I could
definitely if you know if I got in a car
accident Lee passed a rocky Dennis right
like I was a cross between like maybe
could be rocky Dennis from a distance
right well how you talk to her sponge
over yes I talk to us Bon Jovi and then
I guess her girlfriend was at the bar
and then she they were a big group and
they started all pointing and like Oh
like over there and I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna get busted
yeah oh look I get out of here because I
saw everybody like [ __ ] kind of
hovering around they wanted to come
around then I'm like someone's gonna
know I'm gonna get punched out but
nobody could be that stupid
yeah that girl did people couldn't have
believed it right so I guy I gotta go
she goes I go I gotta go in a parking
lot I can't be you know and she's like I
gotta get on my steel horse she goes she
goes can I go with you i'ma get next
thing you know I'm in my car making out
with her she's making out
by grabbing her tits and she invites me
to a barbecue the next day because her
son her six or seven year old son is a
big fan no she goes he loves you it's
you're his favorite band can you please
come to the barbecue it's just my
friends no one's gonna make a big deal
no one's gonna take pictures we're not
gonna tell anyone else by the way that's
not that's disturbing on so many levels
because you also have to realize that
even if you were Bon Jovi right can you
imagine like you're a kid right you're
six years old your favorite rock star
you know whoever it is right it's
grabbing your mom's tits that'd be
terrible news well if I came home one
day and my mother had Aziz come on her
[ __ ] collar what are you doing yeah
I'd be like if Hulk Hogan well like like
was going down on my mom junkyard dog
more like more accurate why would you be
mad at Hulk Hogan no I wouldn't be mad
but like the next time like when the
next Wrestlemania came across and I I'd
be like yeah I don't know like an
erection a little bit it'd be tough to
cheer for him like he's like I'm gonna
beat the earthquake and I'm like I don't
know if I want you to beat the
earthquake anymore you were you were
going down on my mom you know well you
know your mom might have liked it wait
in hindsight like now I would grow up
and be like you know what good for my
mom but as a kid I'd be like this is I
don't like this this is weird
well there was a store that slash walked
in in his mom's bedroom and she was in
bed with David Bowie and he was still as
David Bowie fan yeah no playing yeah
name is David Bowie it's Hulk Hogan I
mean you're a wrestling fan it's Hulk
Hogan it is Hulk Hogan Flash's mom [ __ ]
David Bowie why be so bummed out if my
mom [ __ ] David Bowie
it was so hey it was Sambo's Hulk Hogan
it wasn't SD Jones special-delivery
Jones then you're like I had yeah she
was eating chief Jay Strongbow ass yeah
what are you
[Laughter]
animals do in your mom's toilet this
white stuff flying I'm gonna play some
tubes and spit them out so we're having
with the girl you just couldn't go
obvious lie so she says can you please
come you know she gave me her number
alright I'm gonna yeah sure I'll try to
make it so the next angle obviously I
can't go it's daylight they're gonna
know in two seconds when I walk back
they're not Bon Jovi but I felt bad cuz
I figured the kids probably waiting for
me to show up so I actually called the
woman and said look I can't make it I
gotta brush back to New York to go in
the studio now you're on the phone your
voice that can't be what Bon Jovi sounds
like but the kid might not know how I
was a kid well I didn't get on the phone
with the kid yet so I told the mom I
can't make it I got to go back to New
York we got to go back in the studio
it sucks I got to ruin my family
vacation but I got to go so I said we'll
put your kid on the phone so I put the
kid came on the phone but hey man I'm
sorry I can't make the party I know your
mom said you're a big fan good luck with
your music and I was looking forward to
meeting you but I can't he's like all
thanks he was all excited so to this day
that kid probably thinks he talks about
Debbie on the phone talking about drove
on the phone probably thinks his mom met
Bon Jovi I hope he's famous and then it
comes back he goes oh my god and he
meets Bon Jovi and I was like what the
[ __ ] you talking about I haven't made
out some girl on the Jenkinson's parking
lot cuz because he yeah he won't know
cuz he just had the phone conversation
his mom knows now like his mom has
watched Bon Jovi on TV since then and
heard Bon Jovi talk you'd be like that's
not you never knows I wash it to
themselves though she may have convinced
herself like that maybe that's her one
night cuz she only saw him once it's
maybe she might be a little drunk so
she's just watching em play drunk is
watching him sing it's my life as the
New Year's ball drops and she's like oh
yeah I'm at remember I know you remember
me how Betty would he called I remember
yeah he called you remember don't you
would fall for not by I'm James de buddy
Don Jamison like some girl thought he
was this guy in a band
my friend Kevin's band she goes Peter
and he goes yeah he went update her for
like six months and like three months
since she found out he wasn't a guy he
goes all man was she pissed he goes she
goes Peter he goes yeah so she told you
is Peter the whole time yeah this is
like the old like like the old school
version of catfish like now on catfish
people lie about their identities online
right and they hold her there this is
this fake thing and they're texting and
they got fake screen names they're
sending fake pictures back then you just
go to girls and just line well then we
just say you're something out a few
times another time in a bar does girl
goes are you Steve
like yo Steve from now on my cash cuz I
haven't seen you since high school
yeah I moved away you know I just figure
I was gonna see how far I could take it
right improv exercise at that point yeah
there's no there's no penalty just you
know if she finds out who cares yeah I'm
a gam not and and she's like I go yeah I
moved away I just moved back here she
was oh my god everyone's been looking
for you we haven't heard from you in
like 10 years again because you know
John and Mary I'm like yeah she goes
they broke up I go they broke up they
were the perfect couple
I know it's unbelievable now he's going
out with I'm like wow she's yeah we
thought you'd be at the Reunion next day
I'm making out with Harvey that's great
that's great just follow the lead right
yeah just follow the lead they're there
laying out there for you you got to just
make it up I never got confused with
anybody but do you know who I thought I
look like when I was younger who did you
think you look like I thought I'd look
like Michael J Fox why I was delusional
I try to think that but you never never
wait close I would reference it on stage
no no no no you mean when you were
performing you thought you had spiky
hair yeah he was hair was never that
short though you don't mean it
you don't mean when you were a kid you
thought you look like Mike no I stayed
after that some of my face someone told
me that and I believed him
oh my and then you had to tell people no
on stage I represent sometimes joke but
it was a it wasn't a joke like you'd
like one of those jokes I'm across which
we yeah I'm one of those like it wasn't
a joke like can you believe sometimes
that I look like Mike no no I was not
pointing on her stupid an observation
was it was as if the audience all felt
like yeah yeah like that was the
reference to make we've all been
thinking hey man Jim Norton says the
stuff we're thinking we were all just
thinking that guy looks like Michael J
Fox you guys are looking at me like yeah
we everyone had a joke are you across
miles between ba-ba-ba-ba-bom so it was
Michael J Fox and somebody else did
everybody go like what's he talking
about now I did Doogie Howser and Sinead
O'Connor that was what I did for you for
cross between right yeah you said Sinead
O'Connor's haircut I know it doesn't
work at all it didn't well it killed dr.
Sam 1992 joke yeah that's when she was
in 92 that was a [ __ ] homerun
yeah nobody alive oh that was a great
because you referenced celebrities that
were it because that doesn't look like
Jim Wow my haircut was short yeah I get
a very belly get a big yuk on the road
like she doesn't look there's a photo
Jim when he was younger and he doesn't
look like Sinead O'Connor or Michael J
my hair was very different then that was
17 then you have the same haircut as
Sinead O'Connor but there's no
resemblance to michael j fox or Doogie
Howser you still get a big laugh KITT
was young looking it looks this looks
like like a young picture of the Jeffrey
Dahmer yeah it does Valley yeah look at
Jim's dad that just just disgust on us
from just like sadness in his face like
this is this is my son this is my family
this is this is Jim Norton my tinted
[ __ ] awful [ __ ] up Pacino is when
he played lefty what was that with
Johnny Depp yeah Danny Donnie Brasco I
got cancer a prick
oh yeah he's probably embarrassed of you
probably probably I should have been he
knew you were knew what you were up to
he knew you were a scumbag no I had a
blazer on well he probably wanted to you
know portray the photo of like a good
American family holiday my mom had her
sweater vest got Jim Norton got Jim
Norton as a kid I can't imagine I can't
imagine like growing up and having to
deal with that like your parents have
Jim Norton as a kid now humiliating it's
probably fine now it's good because
you're successful I don't even know if
it's good now another just kind of
accepted you got your life together a
little bit like you're certainly you're
together yeah pay my bills right exactly
got a nice place oh my god I yesterday
was my birthday as you know and Jim's
you sent me a nice tour sorry you
reminded me of something uh good life is
oh I thought you told your parents on
your birthday yes I talked to both of
them okay they're happy to hear from you
I think maybe I should get a call from
my dad so I talked to him yeah I had a
nice a bumble date nice you did you you
went on bumble for your birthday I did
yeah this place I met I showed up at
this place we meet what place some it
was like a cafe it wasn't gonna be like
a Starbucks
no it wasn't gonna be like a date-date
it was just somebody I talked to a
couple times well yeah let's because I
had to go do a set so like let's just
meet before I go do my set nothing just
a casual encounter a quick T it's good
yeah it's good to get one imagines yeah
braking session in it wasn't gonna be
like we fooled around you never knew we
just chatted the colors it was more like
hey a lot of times I've met girls on
tinder Bumble and like you literally
just have you meet them once and that's
it it's a one-time date and it doesn't
you don't [ __ ] him you don't even kiss
so it's cool I got there and I showed up
and I had some nice mint tea mm-hmm iced
it was really good it's good
that's where to go though well she
didn't come oh yeah I was I left
that's why you didn't comment on the
face so you didn't have nice
conversation you just had mint tea yeah
I was sitting there for a while and she
was late did you bring a newspaper with
you no see mice have been bored I have
my phone and I said the worst of when
you show up and I showed up there I was
like I whatever I'll just go down now
and I ordered this dancing that way for
her to get here and there was like 10
minutes I'm sure she's not here so I
just was like she said she had to do
something
I'm sure yeah I got to do this thing
I'll be like 10 minutes so I just I was
like wait was like 10 minutes 15 minutes
I ordered my tea and it nice and iced it
was all mint leaves was very good oh
great and I'm glad the tea was good I
finally realized she wasn't gonna come
so I just I said I'm like you know let
me know you weren't coming did she text
you direct
she did what'd she say she said she was
really sorry she was doing this thing
she actually called me she didn't say I
went by the window and saw you look like
no she was doing some thing she
apologized she's an actress and she was
doing some she was running a scene and
she was just running a scene late but
she did call and try to apologize about
fuming
I had already left well yeah I had
already left like you stood up for
yourself how long were you there for 20
minutes past when she said she's gonna
be that also longer than that so what
how did you guys
and the conversation I hung up on her
you did yeah you're pissed don't make me
wait twenty minutes like if you're gonna
be late yeah if you do late tell me I'm
on my way but don't do something and
then just disregard them they're waiting
for you well she wasn't gonna be late I
don't know if she wasn't not but I did
in fairness she did call and I did she
apologized she called after you texted
though yeah she wasn't gonna be late I
don't I don't think I don't know but I
did yeah
do you think she's gonna be late if Jim
didn't text her she probably wouldn't
have got in contact yeah she wasn't
gonna show up at all no she wasn't she
might have been running all about it and
she's like I don't feel like they want
it a girl walked by who might have been
her there was one girl who I thought
walked by that might have been her and
then did you like half get out of your
seat oh she's here oh yeah no she just
looked in Kip let me go get the door for
oh it wasn't her but whatever could it
do you think it was her
I don't know I'm 50/50 on Oh
oh yeah that looks just like a profile
picture oh I guess so I guess that
wasn't her yes she's looked in and kept
going oh maybe she's not she probably
thought probably maybe that was the
scene where she was rehearsing yeah a
date yes stand up an old man did you
know it was your birthday no yeah I
didn't think of it until I left I kind
of laughed on myself like you [ __ ]
zero my birthday I'm gonna sit up on
bumble does that kind of put things in
perspective he actually does hammers it
right home Sam just reminded me that
what he said you were doing good I told
her on the phone you should been like
you know on my birthday now cuz if you
already said it was his birthday and
it's you be like god this is weird yeah
it's the guy's birthday and we're going
and I got a first date to me for coffee
why'd you why'd you why'd you figure out
him I don't want to have anything else
going on in your life
yeah I'm a bumble date on your
birthright yeah so yeah it was kind of
like a last-minute thing I was gonna go
down the cellar and she's like I'm down
by this park oh you're in the same area
so she wonderful
she was really close she didn't mention
that no that's usually yeah you could
tell she's probably not lying she's
probably oh I was just gonna be late but
I was going to come but we don't have to
reschedule yeah oh my god Troy you don't
I heard you in a background when when he
said sometimes you just do a like a just
a meet up beforehand yeah but you don't
do that oh yeah you have to you said you
have a one drink maximum listen there
there are some girls that you'll just
kind of go the extra mile for what's the
extra mile the extra mile some girls for
some reason feel like if they sleep with
you the first day they're [ __ ]
I don't know that's crazy but they do
feel that way they want to have at least
the first meeting so think you feel like
okay I felt it out and he's a good guy
or not show up to the first meeting
sometimes well walk by and realized oh
yeah that's him so you just gotta go get
it over with and I've done this to I've
been like oh where do you work where you
know it'll be like oh I'm on you know
whatever whatever Street I'm like oh
cool I'll meet you on the corner and I
just go say hi I like right by my bike
say hi and then leave I'm like there's
the first encounter there it is out of
the way so that's going above and beyond
yeah sometimes like a chick is cool and
you're like oh you know what let's let's
go ahead and grab dinner or whatever
Rayo wrong do you stop your bike yeah
ours of course that's just like a wave
like yeah it's me I'm a bike yeah but
you know you got sometimes you got put
in that work you got to put in like a
half hour a coffee or a drink
yeah just and this guy you know let's
get together in a couple days let's
figure it out just don't think I going
out of the way right I see I see
it's but and then it could be any time
during a day so you not wasting a whole
night with them yep where you did in the
afternoon or something
yeah afternoon maybe after like a like
three four something like that do
anything else anyway unless they don't
show up at all which happens apparently
yeah yep Jim sometimes they don't come
no I mean you've instead of more times
than you'd like to admit I'm sure I have
been sure I happen I remember the last
one was that well there's the girl in LA
that didn't come to the party with you
oh that content yeah yeah I didn't tell
her it was Maria Menounos party we were
going to Maria Menounos it's party I
think Jim you got a you got to come and
you think is he cool if I bring a girl
I'm like definitely and so we were we
were going out there and the girl was
like okay yeah no I'm gonna I'll be
there I'll be there and I watched and I
was like what are we gonna meet this
girl Jenna like why don't we leave and
she's gonna meet me at the hotel right
right and she was gonna meet us at the
hotel he met me at the hotel earlier
that day
right and we had lunch yeah they'd
already had lunch but then she stopped
responding to yaks I may even have her
picture she did apologize again but
there's another piece of [ __ ] she said
she fell asleep
way late in the night he didn't text
them and she was like sorry I fell
asleep no you what am i 15 you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I know you want to sleep what 7
o'clock right that happened I'm looking
to see if I have her picture like a
young a young young 24 year old right in
LA
yeah that's our big lunch we it's a
weekend so you're gonna go to sleep at 7
you know yeah I didn't tell her it was
she's in the business to entertain what
business entertainment somehow she might
be an actress or something I didn't tell
her she wasn't a saint she's a
prostitute no no no that no no I
wouldn't go on a date like that are you
gonna keep using the apps
this was Raya yeah cuz you can strike
gold on that sure you know you just get
you know it's gonna be you know you have
to take your elves three out of ten are
gonna work out something that's a l'eau
yeah well you know look but but there's
no did you know you're not going dinner
date movie a lot doing any of that stuff
they used to have to do yeah yeah okay
so it's worth it do you go meet him meet
him for coffee meet him for a drink so
it's not like it's a friend of a friend
and you meet him at a restaurant then
you have dinner and you get to know each
other and then a week later you go to a
movie and then a week after that you
guys I gotta pick her up at her house
you got to go to a door yeah you know
you have coffee or whatever you meet her
and then you see how it goes yeah yeah
those are fast I don't mind the apps are
quick I think there's no and so even if
you strike out a bunch of times doesn't
matter it's it's like I was gonna have
coffee at this time anyway
right you were here or not it's no less
dignified than meeting in a bar like a
lot of times you meet in an app like
okay you can see a little it about her
life you see a few pictures all right
you talk a little bit like what's the
difference between that and being
introduced by someone you talk a little
bit then you see each other for the
second time so the app is your talk I
mean you meet who cares do you ignore it
you should go for something maybe like
not old but a little older than like you
know mid 20s maybe but I mean that's why
it's the price you pay young girls are
flaky they're flaky yeah it's the price
you pay and a lot of times it's like
they're young 20s mid 20s they're so
used to having their ass
kissed and yes and when you're an older
guy you just don't want to put in the
[ __ ] work you're like I can't do this
well it's also like you were talking
about like sometimes you meet a girl and
she's cool and you actually like hanging
out with her yeah like there's not that
many girls in their mid-20s
they're great conversationalist sorry
they're okay I'm some of them okay I
mean I prefer girls that I've had you
know a little bit of life yeah just
something to talk about yeah yeah I
prefer someone 2830 those are good ages
to date
that's not bad yeah that's fine okay
someone 3035 depend on who they were
yeah yeah the young ones you know she's
so used to blown off guys that she would
just think Jim's gonna try again hey
let's try to meet up again so she
doesn't give a [ __ ] I just won't go yeah
doesn't matter he's not putting up but
he's like no I'm not a 25 year old gonna
kiss your ass and chase you're right
yeah older and I'm like over I
understand that this happens and it's
and I've been a scumbag so many times
that's just karma comes back to bite you
suppose she's going to a friend being
like oh it's just what I thought he
yelled at me like he was my dad yeah
yeah see I need that the girl who has
like a daddy thing that's the girl I'll
do okay with you're at that age now or
the girl who like wants an older guy
there's a lot of girls like an older guy
a lot of them don't a creeped out by it
but a lot of them do and those are the
ones you struck gold with you like you
really do you have your real age on that
I think or close to it yeah mine's like
10 years younger and now I'm just like
ya know I could you're not really oh my
god I don't know I might my publicist
hooked up my facebook page I don't know
what I thought I was the only one that
said that you have to hook it up to
Facebook yes page you know on the fake
account cuz you're probably not gonna
set up your dating apps but they will
set up the Faceman and whatever comes in
to Facebook they age on there so just a
gasps you set up a while like I don't
even know what age you put on pay
attention
right yeah it's that's a show business
thing that's not yeah I'm gonna try on
no idea what you put there yeah no you
could say it's a glitch in the app
because a lot of times they'll say it
the wrong age so let me say I'm not
really this I'm really this you ever
seen that yep where they say like the
age is wrong on the app so it's not a
glitch they're only doing that so you
don't like you don't lose them by
putting a different agent so you fit
into the yeah because you won't get you
won't get you know you're rich but you
shouldn't even do that because if
someone reads that thing at all like
this person's really just say forget it
I'd rather do it on the date and break
it to them I'm running my Facebook right
now I'm seeing I might have lied but not
by much
yeah that's a lot like if a 27 year old
girl wants to put age right you know 22
to 42 right if you're 43 you're gonna
miss that she'll never see your picture
right so you have no shot of matching up
with her then again you know I don't
blame her
so you got yeah that's true so you got
to balance out like the lowest age that
still makes sense yeah like as if you go
in there and be like yeah I'm 38 they're
gonna what
why did you say you're 38 I don't know
where my yeah what age what age do you
have on there Florentine I don't know
it's like it's you know I don't know
what it is but it sides it's like 9 or
10 years younger than I really am
- 6 years you guys for the same reason
yeah take it fit in there I'm gonna make
yeah you're gonna have a lot of girls
like that which also is like girls are
like that's why I set up the parameters
because I want to lose you guys you know
if someone's gonna date you 443 if
you're 49 plus I used my real name said
my real picture so it's Google I'm very
easy to find I guess there's a big
difference between 43 and 49 not really
you don't think so no not that much
really says anyway age ain't nothing but
a number he does yeah there's a big
difference between the 22 and 11
43 and 49 you know most most girls won't
give a [ __ ] if they do all right
we won't quote yeah yeah yeah I'm always
pretty honest about my age I just want
to get lost in the swipe you don't like
not fit into the bracket yeah no I make
sense you got it you got to keep your
options as high as possible yeah I don't
lie about other stuff Jim what ever
happened that girl whose house you went
to and she invited another way to hear
this foreign she said Norton is he's
hanging out with this girl was it was a
friend yeah and I liked her she was
young and he goes over there like in her
20s or whatever and he goes over to hang
out with her at her place yes and she
and her girls brought his own snacks and
he brought his s right he brought odd
nuts with him kids you know he likes
nuts yeah and she was there hanging out
with her girlfriend so it was like that
and then Norton came and joined them
Baba and he got there and they go they
were laughing and he was like what's so
funny and they're like oh you know what
we just did because we thought it was
funny we invited a guy over that we met
on tinder just now so he's coming over
Oh
as a goof as a goof like he's so funny
this is my second time hanging out with
it the first time hanging out whether I
got vibes from her
this was the second time hanging out
with her meaning that's funny
for no you don't know that's funny so
I'm sitting there like I'm like what am
I doing with this girl and like was it
another girl it was another girl friend
with her too so all of a sudden this guy
show I'm like what do you why'd you do
that he's gonna feel like anything
getting annoyed shook you and I'm like
I'd be so pissed off I was him so I kind
of felt bad for this guy and then I'm
like it's a waste of your time too I'm
like I'll stay so the guy showed up and
he was a trooper he was not a bad guy he
was okay and he just [ __ ] kind of
stayed and hung out so that her other
girl for less than just me this guy and
her on the sofa sitting there talking
and me and the guy was trying to
outweigh each other and I'm like what am
i doing
yeah so I just I'm like [ __ ] this I'm
like yeah I'm gonna go I got to get up
or whatever I'm like let him [ __ ] this
girl I don't I was just annoyed but I do
have other communications from her you
do and it's gone okay so she was the one
it wasn't a friend she was the one who
called it as a goof huh yeah then that's
bad didn't you have to go back to get
your salad no I left my salad there but
I went home that's right he brought a
salad too I went home that night but she
did say she did say she was sorry for
that she texted me later and don't read
anything Jim just read from just read
the top three she sent me a text about
we got to hang out she was saying hey
let's hang out and I said something to
her then you can read it out loud the
top three things she said to me in that
text what are the top three top three
lines top three lines yeah there's three
texts up there but we've been pg-13 oh
we've been so pg-13 okay let's properly
hang later this week okay I want you to
[ __ ] my throat oh wow she's a trooper oh
that's great news I didn't do it but
yeah you should have done I can I read
your response no no
why I want to see their nachiketha Oh
is it funny yeah okay it's typical for
guys she says I want you to [ __ ] my
throw where you gonna say is gonna
happen right this is how I want it to go
down basically yeah it's not that bad
no it's nothing that yeah I'd love to
know how you responded if you're
comfortable with it so she said I want
you to I want you to [ __ ] my throat and
he says I would love to lay you on my
bed and hang your head over the edge and
sink my [ __ ] into your mouth that's a
great response so much for pg-13 and she
said mmm let's do that Thursday night
then we didn't though
you shouldn't why yet all these we had a
great plan well I you get busy she gets
bit like it's just he talked her what oh
yeah you do a lot of [ __ ] talking yeah a
lot of talk but no action and sometimes
you just setting it up for another time
yeah and if it ever happens to never
happen she's a late night girl like she
likes to go out late she's actually a
cool person I like I would hang out with
her just and hang with her but um she's
like a late-night you know I'll get
texts from her like 11:30 at night I'm
like no I'm in bed you should date like
a low-level celebrity enough of this
nonsense
oh I don't know you can find a low-level
[ __ ] but like somebody who's just like
kind of Natasha dreams yeah that'd be a
perfect one yeah I can see that
happening sure we're not gonna date a
high level celebrity Troy would wait she
might not yeah Dreamz is my level the
problem with that is the high level
celebrity is you know if Jim's doing a
funny bone in Columbus Ohio Thursday
through Sunday they don't like sitting
in the green room for four days no they
also don't like being famous and having
their boyfriend googled and having my
results come up my results are not
celebrity girlfriend friendly yeah why
don't you date natasha dreams Natasia
well it's up to her okay it seems flirt
with you pretty hard I thought yeah I
know but on the radio it never means
anything you know how it is did you have
you have you had interactions with her
off the air we chatted we'd never met up
no we talked about eating but again I
wouldn't I would eat with her I wouldn't
nice gonna [ __ ] her either yeah but you
might that's the point right weirdo dude
I'm a weirdo as I get older what do you
mean I don't [ __ ] that often why not
don't scary world you're worried about
AIDS
well yeah there's a lot of thing you
have to worry about the diseases
pregnant pregnancies a big there's a lot
of [ __ ] with her you don't be worried
about yeah you're right but Noah's gonna
get the movie jr. and some as a general
rule you know it is Jim you gotta
[ __ ] get a start being very careful
yeah we'll get a vasectomy
oh yeah yeah so uh why don't you get a
vasectomy
you're right I haven't yes don't I
should yeah yeah and a nice thing about
that you can't get AIDS if you have a
vasectomy oh yeah yeah I don't know if
you know that yeah that's true that's
true know that yeah I know it's true